to talk about apprenticeship provision
and what there is um uh we have a
business engagement team reports into
Bill uh and um and the head of that team
or member that team we'll be very happy
to um meet with them and talk to them
about the opportunities that that we
have got there's there's a generic piece
in there as well about English and math
um there are funding and uh funding
rules around um uh needing to have
English and maths at level two for a
level three apprenticeship be working
towards it for a level two
apprenticeship um again happy to pick up
with with whoever raised this around the
uh if exor are taking a different
approach to us but one of the things
that we are looking at for next year is
to uh embed English and maths more into
the apprenti ship delivery framework so
at the moment um we have been offering
English and math as a kind of bolt on uh
generally on on a Monday and then you
might have your day release program on a
Tuesday or Wednesday that has not been
popular as you could probably uh
understand with employers and actually I
think some of the some of the question
is actually that employers are choosing
ex rather than us uh because the uh math
and English program is more flexible
there we are doing something about that
from September and uh would anticipate
being able to be a bit more specific
about that in the next few weeks but
that's part of of looking to see whether
we can uh structure our English and math
delivery for apprenti ships uh in a
different way but again be very very
happy to pick that feedback up in more
detail with um I don't know if it was uh
counselor it was I just cated some
questions from different people um but I
can get back again um Julie's my head of
business engagement or myself or John
bow our head of apprenticeships would be
very happy to pick that up and indeed
pick your brains as to to to what was
thought behind that okay thank you and
the next one you've already spoken about
the um touring program but you didn't
mention any numbers you said you had 2
200 um on the Erasmus schemes but uh
we've got broadly similar on cheering um
it is um he's slightly more bureaucratic
than arasmus um which is surprising
potentially um and uh there are changes
to next year's program um but one of the
big advantages of juring over arasmus is
that it isn't limited as Sean was
describing to Europe um so we have got
some more interesting uh
destinations um it is very popular um it
is the right thing that we want to do
for Learners we are an area where we
have Learners going out on Aras saering
programs for whom it is their first trip
out of Devon let alone out of the
country um we always tell the anecdote
of one student who on the coach arriving
on the M5 insisted on getting up and
taking some photos because they'd heard
of a out away but never seen one um
which is very very sad um and it's
something that we really want to address
and make sure that all our programs uh
have access to arasmus during uh
opportunities uh and indeed some of our
programs uh also have Student Self
funded trips um there's a trip to South
Africa uh for example that goes every
couple of years to look at animal
conservation so some some really great
trips we've got the feedback session
next Tuesday from our group of students
that have just been to aoras in France
um lucky things skiing ice climbing um
but also learning how to run a uh ski
shallow and it's always fascinating to
hear the kind of context of those
Learners who some of whom are learning
how to clean and cater for the very
first time uh their parents are invited
to those as well and you always get some
very interested parents um whose first
comment is well you've never done that
at home dear so um it is it is quite um
life changing on a number of ways for
our students and and we will will
continue to to push governments to make
that program as widely available as
possible so is that something that
you're hoping will grow and absolutely
we we would like it to be available to
every student and also to support our
opportunities to drive attendance and
behaviors as well so that it's can be um
part of the reward model uh for uh that
developing skill set yeah we when we did
a formal EV evaluation of our program
previously um 11% had never been haven't
been out the country previously when
they came back um the Learners had
better attendance and better
attainment um so so there was cly a
correlation there um the new scheme as
as Bill said is um covers the whole
world but the money is less and the
bureaucracy is
greater and
um so we we might look and we've not yet
um achieved this but I think there might
be a nice connection with
philanthropists because you know one of
the things from my experience the
philanthropists quite often like is to
be able to see firsthand the benefit of
the um of your giving that you make and
being able to sponsor somebody to take
part on some of these programs is one of
the ways and then get a meet them on the
way back and see what difference is made
is you know something that I'm sure
might be quite rewarding if we can um we
can package that together but again
that's something something that we would
look to you know engage Partners in I'm
just looking to link that to other
questions that that come in around
floating offshore wind um and uh
slightly different um we had an exchange
visit and have a sign memor memorandum
of understanding uh with colleagues in
Morocco um uh there's an institution
over there called f morray who are world
leaders now in solar power uh they work
as you would imagine very closely with
Tex links um and the potential cable
through to aviscott and the work there
so we're working closely with
Excellence thank
you sorry councelor Pennington but um we
are looking to ensure that our students
and their students have opportunities to
understand the very different contexts
of things like solar where frankly in
Morocco land space is not an issue
whereas clearly over here the
availability of land for massive solar
Farms is such such an issue so we we're
trying to give that International
context in a regional and local context
as well I was just wondering whether as
a committee we could contact like
central government and express our
support after speaking to you and
hearing your passion for the touring
program and the need for more of it
because we are isolated here and you're
talking about deprivation in torage and
it's really sort of lifechanging for
these young people help sh I could guess
I'll leave F writer to draft you a
letter that you might like to send yeah
that would be really
good can we put that on the
action we don't do we need to vote on
it no second councel Hudson Sor a quick
question we talk about what are the
financial implications for students you
about versies you talk about enabling
people to do things with uh
philanthropists funding them what is is
is it a scheme for those who have got
access to funding no we because it
really concerns me sometimes these
programs require a lot of support from
families so we asked for a contribution
of £150 for uh the trips um um if
students are suffering hardship whether
that's Fe or H level then we make sure
that bseries are available to them to
support those trips um but we also find
that the and it's still a lot of money
we appreciate that1 150 but it does
create a family and individual buy into
to the trip that if it is fully funded
we sometimes don't get uh but we will
also help for example with the cost of
applying for a passport if needed so for
students that have got genuine hardship
uh we will fully cover the cost um but
our first first ask is is for that
150s thank you because it isn't just
150 it's kitting out your young person
to go to another country um the right
Footwear the right
clothing um as you so rightly the
passports um inoculations if they're
going to a foreign country and they need
to be so we have we have a hardship fund
um for 16 to 18s and for our adults um
and we seek to ensure that that is
available for uh any V value added
program uh that will support There are
rules that say that we can't certainly
for 16 to 18 year olds charge for core
quite rightly for core education
uh but something like a cheering arasmus
program that's exactly what those
bseries are for and we look
sympathetically on requests for those
thank you that's fantastic because the
program sounds incredible
it's than you just on the hardship fund
is it fully used or do you get money
left over year after year because I know
some hardship funds around different
organizations don't always get taken up
um it's mixed um so our 16 to8 program
is generally uh fully utilized uh our
adult program has been um less
so um and we do really encourage uh all
our students to check their
eligibility and seek to make sure that
our rules are as lenient as possible and
sometimes become more lenient during the
year um if we look like we will be
underspending so would you need to could
you use more money if you had it in the
hardship funds are you denying students
because you run out of money uh
generally we the thing we could do with
is more local flexibility in the
Criterion that can be
applied rather than necessarily more
money but we if we if the rules were
more flexible then more money would be
very welcome and certainly we would
never turn down the opportunity to spend
more money on our students and one of
those things that was raised uh
previously about the um the digital
disadvantage and um a gap that
um we want to make sure that our
Learners have a minimum standard of um
digital technology available to them and
if there was a more generous um program
of that we do provide laptops that's one
of the things that they're they're
they're funded for but you would be able
to say yeah but have you got a
smartphone as well um have you got um
what about broadband connection at home
you know equipping those uh those
Learners so that they can take full
advantage of the ways that they can
learn would be uh think so yeah that was
what we would do if we would get you
know if we did get more money are you
aware of the Joseph rry Foundation uh
announcement this week not an
announcement this week okay just stated
that um a third of the Tor districts and
my my Deputy leader will say it's not in
there I got to read it properly but a
third of households and torage are in
deprivation young families and that is
exclusion on its own Merit basically so
it goes back to the hardship questions
again because education provides the
foundation for the stepping stones for
the future and uh um we've got a lot of
evidence here that there is need and we
would like to support you in need to get
education to guys that are excluded from
education basically and that's the a
real message I would want to get
across thank
you um it's question it's about school
counselors and proactivity around um uh
a bullying policy bullying yeah I guess
that links him with mental health as
well which is another question later on
yeah and and I I don't know whether the
term capsel is meant in the the kind of
professional counselor um uh uh sense or
whether it's people who will speak to
students about their beh
um we
um I think might have been the wrong
spelling we
um we don't tolerate bullying at the um
at the college we monitor those things
very carefully um we have seen as I said
earlier in terms of our safeguarding U
uh reports uh an increase incidence of
peer on peer um uh kind of safeguarding
um work we take those as say very
serious they involve um a a three stage
action plan that involves their parents
as well and um can lead if the if the
learner doesn't modify their behavior um
to um them being excluded which is a one
of the you know is the follow-up part of
that question um we usually find that
that process of Education um about why
bullying isn't acceptable and why you're
not going to get on in life if you carry
on in that sort of way um means that uh
we we rarely have to exclude um learners
but it's something that we will do if
they because you you can't tolerate
people um adopting those sorts of
behaviors in your college
um where were we so that that covered
the excluding people so you do sometimes
but very rarely so yes we do and there
are red lines that uh we can't and won't
tolerate and will
exude um then next one are this current
cohort of students more or less hopeful
and aspirational than previous cohorts
are they seeing more or less mental
health issues with students and
previously we covered the mental health
bit um earlier yes we are seeing
increased um uh instance of mental
health issues and responding with a
range of packages the
um question about um more or less
hopeful or aspirational is a um
interesting one and this cohort I
think immedate the immediate the first
generation after the first cohort after
covid it wasn't they were less
aspirational I think they were felt
liberated from the being locked up in
their bedrooms for um a long period of
time but at the same time hadn't had the
sorts of things that give you a sense of
purpose and what you might want to do
because you hadn't had chance to
do a work experience uh an employer at
school and then go I'd quite like to be
a dentist or you know you know I I could
be you know an electrical engineer you
know that and which gives you a kind of
sense
so the I don't you I um continue to
be amazed and at the the ambition that
our our students have and
um and the their effectiveness in
realizing um that ambition and going on
to to do great things
um I think they're they're hopeful but
also realistic about the the state of
the world at the moment and um and so
talking about those things is an
important part of you know being at the
you know being at the college I think we
still suffer from a number of students
that don't realize just how talented
they are and certainly when you talk to
students students in the early days of
their
programs um and they start to describe
things that they understand the things
they know uh what they uh how they might
want to apply
those it is disappointing sometimes that
they don't see that they are remarkable
talents and that they can achieve
probably more than than they realize I
think our Educators and our teams are
very good at bringing out those
strengths and those skills
um where perhaps we as a region and as a
local still suffer is that those uh
aspirations are often seen to only be
fulfilled uh in the big cities and away
from the area and it's certainly
something that we're working uh with
local employers uh and events like today
Marine Futures and and various other
events to really push into the minds of
young people the opportunities that
exist on their doorstep and the you
don't always need to move away to uh
have the most fulfilling and uh and
Broad ranging career um and so we're
trying to work with with Paul uh with
tvk with kemple uh I was with um IGI uh
today um from bford um some fantastic
jobs that are available in the in the
local area and uh again not trying to uh
to stop people moving away and
experiencing other parts as we've
described with arasmus uring but but
recognizing you don't have to so I think
um working together we can support young
people in that aspiration raising thank
you and next one's about the child care
crisis so had someone well I've got two
little ones myself and talking to other
parents there is a real child child care
crisis out there and that knock on
impact on gender equality because a lot
of the time it does fall back on the mom
to sort of take the kids to school and
pick them up and the knock on effects of
that on employment and education
opportunities for women um so what and
with that increase in funding that the
government says they're providing from
nemon old children in within the next is
it next year they're bringing that in
but who is going to look after these
children which are going to be funded
because there's already a struggle to
find places you have to it says on here
you have to get your name on the list
before you're even pregnant to find a
child minder who lives near it's
serious so what is the college doing are
you looking to um educate more recruit
more child minders to be out there
locally two two things actually yeah and
I the um the
one which is about that accessibility of
opportunities for um people with um
small children um when we're we talked
about the adult experience and the
design that we're trying to do on that
and and start off with not these are the
things that we do and we push them at
you but to say okay well what what sort
of experience are the Learners that
we're trying to attract looking for and
so one of those things is um can we put
um education for our adults on at the
times that it's convenient and if you
have got children and things if you do
that's one of the complications in life
um one of the things but it may mean you
can't come along to your normal session
in on a Tuesday evening or whenever it
is I part of the new offer that I'd like
us to get to is that all of those
sessions are recorded so just if you do
miss you don't miss out on your
continued learning if you're back home
because your child's you not well then
you can do something the bigger response
uh is around
educating and training the people who
will create that Workforce that you
highlight or the comment highlights uh
just here so we have have um earliest
provision at level two um we have an
expanded provision um in we've had that
advanceable where we're looking to
expand the provision in tivan and then
we have t levels um uh that you can you
can work to as well that that enables
that that kind of career progression so
that we've seen that same opportunity
this is the the thing about looking at
the changes in the labor market and
Regulation and saying what's that going
to mean for us as a college and how can
we make sure we respond so we're
expecting to see increasing applicants
for those programs that are there ready
to meet that that need and
um well I'll be very pleased if it if if
it does do because you know um more
students is is all all good for us so
you're going to go out there and promote
it and say come and yeah Lear be a child
minder in ABS absolutely um because
there will be well there already is
there will be that need
sure there is always the problem that
there is an awful lot of minimum minim
minimum wage employment as well in those
sectors and uh we are working with child
care providers and others to
increasingly talk about what creates the
interest in working in that sector and
so it's it's is a very much a uh an
employer College linked um push to into
the schools to try and persuade young
people uh and career Changers and uh
women returners in particular that
that's a career that is available to
them and a worthwhile one one of our
Learners last year I think it was um off
from the level three program got a place
on the Norland nannies um program where
it's the kind of the elite Nanny's uh uh
program where they kind of provide that
care to the stars and earn 70 80,000
pounds a year providing those services
so that was quite a prestigious thing
for that one to get I think there's
going to be a much bigger need locally
um for exactly the reasons that you you
mentioned um we we talked a fair a bit
about the next um bit and our uh the
opportunities and our responsibilities
around the CTIC sea opportunities and X
links and what have you um culture do
you want to say a bit about that um
reset on the cultural strategy uh board
um for Northern Devon uh we are working
actively uh with uh Chris Fuller um uh
here and uh with his equivalence uh
within North Devon uh we are looking as
North T Futures as to how we ensure that
the culture strategy is embedded across
uh our piece uh we see that as critical
to developing uh sustainable communities
uh and sustainable towns and uh as I say
working with Chris on and the Burton art
gallery for example um in uh
opportunities for our students to engage
more within culture um increasingly
popular over the last three years have
been our uh Performing Arts music and
indeed fine art programs uh at all
levels um we'd expected them to drop off
uh particularly as there was the
economic downturn has been quite the
reverse um we're working very very
closely with Alison Mills uh and that
team on the flourishing culture strategy
that's good I'm lead member for culture
so I'm pleased fantastic thank
you um and then Council Hawkins were
these all your
questions so um I have responsibility
for the process for uh addition learning
support ALS um uh within the college um
both for exam support and for um initial
assessment of need um I'm not aware that
we have any particular backlog uh for uh
in college ALS assessments there is a
huge backlog for Education Health and
Care uh plan assessments within the
County Council which they are uh they
have a number of strategies to work on
um but um if there are specific issues
that that individuals are seeing I'd be
very happy to pick those up uh
individually I'm not aware of any any
particular issue and the majority of ALS
um uh diagnosis is self referral um so
students letting us know that they have
an additional need uh we're looking at
uh how we roll out moreal additional
learning support uh for our
apprenticeships um and making sure that
the same opportunities to gain
additional support run across all our
programs and we' talked a bit about
hardship as well um specific question
about the sandwich box or um
basement um uh the sandwich box is one
of the um uh the hubs that sha was
talking about for students with
additional needs um it's named The
Sandwich Box um it got that name about
four years ago when we uh sort to run it
as a cafe um uh offering kind of Greg
style food um it wasn't popular as an
individual Outlet so we moved that
across to the main uh Food Hall we are
looking at communal spaces um and study
areas um we are unfortunately one of the
increasing number now of colleges that
have um reinforced uh erated autoclave
concrete um in the building
um and uh the reason that that's
relevant is that it's taken out our
primary study space uh our Learning
Resource Center big uh area of the
college uh which had quiet study had um
uh computer-based study space uh we were
expecting an announcement today which
hasn't uh materialized uh from the
Department for Education uh as to uh how
they're going to uh support report uh
and indeed allow us to develop u a
response to that we hope uh that we will
have by the summer that space back in in
use and therefore there will be more
space available to students uh in the
meantime we have looked to open up
additional spaces and are happy to take
further questions or suggestions on on
what other spaces might be
needed
um again uh one in my patch affordable
food
options uh we look to price our food
competitively we have a Coster outlet
that is about 2third half of the uh of
the high street price but still
expensive um because of the on costs of
of having the cost of brand uh we have
meal deals within our food Hall um food
prices for us just like food prices for
everyone else have gone through the roof
uh we do provide um for those students
that are eligible uh A5 pound a day uh
free meal um that can be used for
breakfast or lunch or both um which is
increasingly used um I'm sad to say um
and we try and make that available with
support of Deon County Council through
the holidays uh but again happy to take
any kind of detailed feedback on uh
things that you think we could do better
on that um and then the last two I think
we've covered the law teacher but um
Sean I don't if you wanted to say
something about exam boards and
universities the
um in terms of information to um uh
universities about um particular
mitigating um circumstances
the they often don't take an awful lot
of note in relation to those things I
had this involved with um an awarding
body uh last year that had um uh
difficulties and the the the
presentation of that information to
universities was problematic what we're
looking to do more is to provide that
additional support to try and make sure
that
um the resulted slip grades that we can
recover those um in time before the
final exams will be the um the the
priority action for us because I think
it's the one that would be more
effective in terms of you know helping
those those Learners that have been
affected um to get where they need to
get
to thank you very much for that very
detailed presentation and answering all
of our questions I found it really
useful I think everyone else did um take
away a lot and talk about at our Parish
Council level and word of mouth and yeah
it's been really thank you for
coming thank you for the opportunity and
thank you for the um the questions
that's um yeah made us think about some
thank
you any other questions I think we had
quite a
few you're free to
go um but stay in touch and we'll get a
letter sorted about the touring program
that
yeah
yeah or is there anything else that so
we'll send that off is there anything
else that we can do as a council that's
what we normally
ask
good thank you good night good
night
um consideration of the forward plan
number
nine we
got so we've
got oh yeah there we are 13th of March
active tor and
lendy coming and 24th of April the PW
well foundation I think active torch and
lendy they're definitely agreed to come
haven't they um I've I plan to contact
Jud Jud Gentry tomorrow about um I
declare interest because I'm on the
board
for a l um then do confirmed at the at
the meeting in December so yeah pick
well I I was going to get in contact
with as well
so and we don't go any further than that
because it's the ATM is that right do we
plan into the future
or
yeah but we have talked about Westwood
housing and Royal
Mail um chair I can add those on to
underneath um so they don't get
forgotten about and and we can to put
those on for the future next for next
year are you happy um or would you
rather the Roy mail last asked in maybe
instead of the pwell foundation um well
have you had a response from the pwell
have we invited pwell we have provision
yeah well it'll have to wait I mean I I
take um councilor Harding's point that
you know this is an ongoing problem and
it's not going to be solved in a minute
if
ever so if we have them on the list for
future invitations Royal M post office
and I think Westwood housing's already
on there isn't it by by the Autumn
hopefully I need to do it this
year okay is everyone
happy thank you I declare the meeting
closed